Buonasera Buonasera a tutti Allora io
sono stato coinvolto Probabilmente
perché mi sono sempre occupato in
maniera ind diretta del doppio della
copia in letteratura e al cinema il tema
del doppio è stato sfruttato tante volte
pensate a dottor Jacky le Mister heid
all'ombra di Peter Pan a Splash una
sirena manattan C'era sempre un qualcosa
che si sdoppi Ava o un
amore contrastato o un personaggio con
una personalità nascosta io fin da dal
primo film inconsciamente Perché queste
cose dopo tanti anni Si si
razionalizzano ma all'inizio uno lo fa
solo perché si diverte io con ratataplan
avevo
creato 40 4 anni fa una sorta di
anticipazione dell'avatar cioè prendevo
un robot costruivo un robot a mia
immagine a assignan e lo mandavo in giro
per la città al posto mio non non
pensavo al metaverso non pensavo a tutte
le meraviglie tecnologiche che sono
accadute dopo Però l'idea che qualcuno
mi potesse rappresentare come un avatar
meglio di me mi affascinava come come
meccanica di commedia e il tema del
doppio l'ho sfruttato anche in altri
film Cioè in l'una e l'altra c'era una
un'ombra che abbandonava il suo corpo
per cui Peter Fleming è la fuga
dell'ombra col patto col diavolo era un
un'anticipazione letteraria ma a me
interessava come chiave di commedia e
una cosa che in quel caso mi era stata
fatta notare sempre a posteriori era che
in quel caso la personalità nascosta
della maestra elementare era stranamente
migliore dell'originale e questo io non
ci avevo pensato pensavo che sì la
maestra era tutta molto rigorosa voleva
sembrare molto molto seria mentre la sua
ombra era la voglia di divertirsi di
cantare di giocare di liberarsi da tutte
le costrizioni a cui la società la
obbligava Ecco mi hanno detto Guarda che
di solo Mister è peggio del dottor jaill
Di solito la personalità nascosta il
doppio che uno si tiene dentro se lo
tiene dentro perché non lo vuole fare
uscire Questo era il secolo scorso Io
poi c' ho giocato Addirittura in Stefano
Quante storie e si raccontavo la vita di
sette vite diverse dello stesso
personaggio per cui i doppi si
moltiplicavano
ma era il
1900 poi arrivando al nuovo millennio
che è i 20 anni di cui molti di voi
hanno il ricordo ho visto prima in sala
molta gente giovane che non si ricorda
cosa succedeva negli anni 7080 90 ma dal
2000 è cambiato tutto nell'audiovisivo
perché è entrato il digitale al posto
dell'analogico si è buttata via la
pellicola e abbiamo tutti lavorato col
digitale Cosa vuol dire questo non è
solo un
problema di lavoro di mestiere mestieri
che sono morti e mestieri che sono nati
è proprio un linguaggio diverso è una
dei cambiamenti fondamentali Io me lo
ricordo bene perché nel 2000 circa avevo
assistito ad una presentazione a Milano
di un di un film che non era ancora
uscito Era Shrek è uscito nel 2001 che
poi ha avuto tante tanti seguiti allora
è venuto questo tecnico italiano che
lavorava a Los Angeles e ci ha fatto
vedere sullo schermo le prime prove di
questo Orco verde che recitava come una
persona vera era una copia di un attore
ma era una copia non perché veniva
disegnato come un attore perché veniva
proprio animato da un attore erano le
prime esercitazioni le prime
applicazioni del Motion Capture Motion
Capture è la cattura del Movimento
praticamente un attore un mimo Eh si
muoveva con dei sensori che tracciavano
delle linee che causavano poi il
movimento del disegno animato Ma di più
con sharek avevano perfezionato questa
tecnica con l'emotion capture cioè la
cattura delle emozioni che era una cosa
fantastica perché tutti questi sensori
venivano messi sul viso di un attore e
questo attore Recitava con una sua
espressione e il l'orco verde faceva le
stesse espressioni mi ricordo che io
vedendolo avevo pensato ma qui cambierà
il mondo perché fino ad oggi abbiamo
avuto i doppiatori quelli che doppiano
la voce di un attore da oggi in poi
avremo i doppiatori di emozioni
doppiatori di movimento che era un po'
quello che stava accadendo poi abbiamo
fatto delle domande perché eravamo tutti
affamati di di novità su questa nuova
tecnolog
abbiamo detto Ma a cosa vi serve Oltre
che far muovere i cartoni animati dice
ma per esempio se voi in futuro potremmo
fare degli uomini veri e propri e se uno
non sa recitare lo Disegniamo come un
uomo vero ma poi gli mettiamo un attore
che sa recitare e che gli comunicherà
tutte le espressioni e i movimenti che
che invece dovrebbe fare se sapesse
recitare Ma noi non eravamo contenti
abbiam detto vabbè ma tutto questo non
sarebbe meglio prendere un attore che sa
recitare e dice sì Però potrebbe servire
anche per ringiovanire un attore che
anziano per far recitare un attore che è
morto nel 2000 sta cosa qui era
fantascienza per noi il primo film di
Shrek è uscito nel 2001 Ma che film sono
usciti quell'anno lì è uscito il primo
film del Signore degli Anelli è uscito
il primo film di Harry
Potter e allora lì c'è da fare una
riflessione queste emotion capture
questo modo di far recitare delle copie
al posto degli attori veri ha cambiato
l'immaginario
cinematografico perché se ci pensate
bene Il Signore degli Anelli è il primo
di una trilogia che poi è stata seguita
da Hobbit che poi è stata seguita da
King Kong sempre Peter Jackson la
diretta sempre la sua casa di produzione
in Australia ma sapete perché perché lui
per fare il primo film del Signore degli
Anelli ha fatto andare in
Australia 150 famiglie dei migliori
animatori illustratori e studiosi di
Tolkien e questo ha cambiato la vita di
150 famiglie Tu non li puoi fare andare
in Australia per 6 mesi per un anno per
2 anni che è la lavorazione di un film
Gli devi promettere che per 15 anni Gli
dai lavoro e allora Peter Jackson ha
dovuto fare sette lungometraggi Harry
Potter ne ha fatti 8-9 Shrek ne ha fatti
qu cque e da quel giorno il cinema è
diventato seriale cioè quando tu
spendevano per costruire dei modelli
tridimensionali e tanto valeva la pena
usarli anche per un secondo per un terzo
per un quarto film Naturalmente dovevano
essere film di successo Non è che R
facevi cinque film se non c'era successo
Però tutto questo si come dire
serializzata al mondo del
cinema nel 1900 era completamente
diverso quando io ho cominciato a fare
film con ratataplan il produttore che
avevo era uno dei più grandi era il più
grande produttore italiano non sono nato
nel mondo del cinema per cui casualmente
mi sono ritrovato a essere prodotto da
Franco Cristaldi il produttore
illuminato quello che aveva prodotto a
cord aveva prodotto i film di Rosi di
Ponte Corvo di Gregoretti cioè aveva
prodotto i film d'autore più importanti
italiani dei due decenni precedenti e mi
ricordo che quando andavamo a presentare
il film in giro una delle sue frasi
tipiche era il cinema è una fabbrica di
prototipi per cui è un'industria
insicura dove io produttore non potrò
mai essere C di un successo quindi non
saprò mai se il mio investimento mi
ritornerà Perché ogni volta affronto
assieme all'autore un prototipo che se
va bene va bene se non va bene ne dovrò
fare un altro ora con tutto quello che
ho detto dopo il 2001 il cinema non è
più stato fabbrica di prototipi è stato
fabbrica di
serialità Perché i film quando avevano
successo venivano replicati Pens a
Batman a Superman a tutti i supereroi
della Marvel ai dinosauri cioè tutto il
cinema Blockbuster uscito negli ultimi
20 anni nasce da questa intuizione e da
questa tecnologia io posso disegnare
virtualmente un
personaggio lo faccio muovere lo faccio
volare G do super poteri ma una volta
che l'ho costruito che mi sono costruito
tutti i modelli per poterlo
muovere come un burattino tanto vale che
faccio la seconda la terza la quarta la
quinta puntata ora oggi siamo oltre
perché oggi siamo finiti addirittura
nella nelle stagioni cioè non si fa più
un film che dura un'ora e mezza si fa
una stagione che dura 10 puntate e la
seconda stagione la terza stagione la
quarta stagione per cui questo concetto
della serialità della copia all'infinito
di un personaggio che vive n avventure è
diventata industria Cioè oggi nessun
produttore è più interessato a leggere
una sceneggiatura di un di un film
perché tutti vogliono avere tra le mani
qualcosa di moltiplicabile di
duplicabile e questo è un problema
perché non tutti lavoriamo in
un'industria che investe tantissimo nel
primo film e poi può vivere di rendita
per 10 anni perché fa la seconda la
terza e la quarta puntata la nostra
cinematografia non è in questa
situazione deve sempre fare i conti con
dei budget ridotti e con un budget
ridotto non si può fare un film di
effetti speciali o anche solo di azione
con delle grandi scene di di di di di
movimento di effetti speciali di
distruzioni da lì nasce il fatto che poi
il cinema italiano dicevano si svolgeva
sempre in due camere e cucina ma non era
una estetica del Neorealismo come
abbiamo creduto per tanti anni era un
obbligo commerciale noi dovevamo fare
dei film con dei budget molto
piccoli finita questa descrizione di
come è cambiato il cinema e il e la
proposta audiovisiva dal 900 al
2000 oggi se quando mi hanno chiesto di
partecipare a un a un Ted sulla copia al
cinema non mi è venuto in mente quello
che ho detto fino adesso quello che ho
detto fino adesso è quello che ha
causato il l'obbligo a lavorare con
mentalità seriale a me è venuto in mente
che oggi Se vai da un produttore ti
chiede non tanto una sceneggiatura
originale ti chiede di rifare un film
che hanno già fatto in Francia l'anno
scorso il remake il remake non è un
remake fatto dopo 30 anni cioè Scarface
era un film che è stato fatto dal Pacino
e 30 anni prima 40 anni prima l'avevan
fatto agli americani in un'altra maniera
con altri attori e quello si può capire
dopo 30 anni rifai un film d'azione No
noi in Italia stiamo rifacendo i film
francesi dell'anno scorso i film
spagnoli dell'anno scorso i film
australiani dell'anno scorso e allora
una cosa che vorrei invitarvi a
riflettere è perché i francesi non
vendono il loro film in Italia perché
vendono i diritti perché noi lo possiamo
rifare in Italia con i nostri attori
perché è cambiato il mondo perché ogni
cinematografia non si può permettere di
fare delle cose originali e i gli
editori le televisioni i network quelli
che sono oggi i produttori di
audiovisivo vogliono avere la certezza
del risultato altro che Ipo altro che
rischio imprenditoriale vogliono vedere
il film che film vuoi fare tu ti faccio
vedere un film francese e te lo rifaccio
uguale anni fa questo fenomeno è
cominciato con Benvenuti al Nord che era
il film francese che abbiamo rifatto
Benvenuti al sud ma adesso non ve lo
dicono più neanche che sono dei remake
escono come film normali con uno Star
System italiano Favino Edoardo Leo
persone albanese registi come Riccardo
Milani tutte persone assolutamente degne
di fare cinema che lavorano solo
riproducendo o spesso riproducendo film
appena fatti da un'altra cinematografia
anche noi ce ne avvantaggi perché
perfetti sconosciuti è un film che può
vantare il maggior numero di repliche di
copie di copie internazionali però hanno
venduto il format hanno venduto la
sceneggiatura e poi ognuno se l'è
rifatto nel suo paese Con i suoi attori
ora capite che tutto questo sposta
completamente e i flussi di successo e
di guadagno perché ogni attore ogni
sceneggiatore ogni regista lavora a casa
sua e poi il produttore vende i diritti
in Francia per rifare il film ammesso
che i francesi rifacciano i nostri film
tolto perfetti sconosciuti non mi
risulta che il nostro cinema venda molti
molti soggetti E questa situazione per
assurdo è la stessa situazione che c'è
anche in televisione perché la
televisione ormai da anni da più di 15
anni io il primo grande fratello era del
2001 anche lui non a caso sempre quel
fatidico anno e quei Format lì sono
tutti Format che vengono riprodotti
nazione per Nazione su una bibbia su una
sceneggiatura rigorosamente uguale se
avete visto Il Milionario che è un film
indiano di una quindicina d'anni fa
sembrava di vedere il migli orario con
jry Scotti mancava solo jry Scotti ma
c'erano le stesse inquadrature la stessa
scenografia le stesse musiche lo stesso
ritmo di trasmissione e lo stesso sapore
non c'era Jerry Scotti ecco tutto questo
per dire che da adesso in poi forse non
avremo più neanche la necessità di
andare a comprare un Format perché ci
sarà un'intelligenza artificiale che
elaborerà in base alle richieste che un
produttore che un network che una
televisione farà elaborerà i canovacci i
Format e le sceneggiature che un un
editore ritiene essere un successo
garantito tutto questo non ha niente a
che vedere col prototipo di tanti anni
fa con una creatività più originale non
so se questo è un bene o se è un male
Non so se è un momento di passaggio che
avrà Poi farà nascere nuove creatività
ma speriamo che poi la creatività non
venga gestita solo artificialmente da
sedicenti intelligenze
[Applauso]
Grazie